pas même manière que pour les
déplacements publics du président dans
la question que vous avez posé
précédemment il a pu arriver que j'ai
une arme sur moi à l'occasion d'un
déplacement privé
est ce que vous aviez une mission
particulière de sécurité puisque vous
avez dit que votre tâche était une tâche
de coordination et organisation de
déplacements
est-ce que s'agissant des déplacements
privés votre tâche était la coordination
et l'organisation du déplacement ou est
ce que en plus il y avait une mission de
sécurité alors de la même manière que je
voulais préciser pour les déplacements
officiels
j'avais exactement les mêmes fonctions a
les mêmes missions dans le cadre des
déplacements privés sauf que j étais
tout seul chez encore